oh my God
oh
my god
oh you're like you're like a rash taking
over my body
a good rash happy Friday everybody and
it's Friday so you know what that means
first let's welcome tonight's guests
unlike Kathy hokel he's actually
qualified to be Governor former New York
Congressman Lee zelded
still bless your heart and tear your
theories apart co-hosts are the bottom
line on Fox Business Jake and McDowell
he looks like your favorite Applebee's
manager co-host of fox and friends first
Todd Pyro
and finally like a flash flood she shows
up where she's not wanted and causes a
lot of damage Fox News contributor Kat
too
yes those jalapeno poppers were cold
Todd movies huh yes all right all right
okay before we get to some news stories
it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck we will take one of the writers out
strip him naked and set him on fire
all right here we go this week in New
Jersey more than 500 pounds of pasta was
found mysteriously dumped in the woods
in response one enraged resident is
vowing Revenge
[Applause]
according to report CBS was supposedly
losing billions on James corden's late
night show and that was just on catering
[Laughter]
the lesbian dating app her told females
who object to dating trans women to
delete their accounts and go back to
meeting other lesbians the old-fashioned
way while shopping at Home Depot
at least you'll know what equipment
you're getting
came from here
a man with a self-proclaimed micro penis
is going viral after revealing how he
breaks the news to potential sex
partners
the man added it could be worse it could
be Microsoft
I was just bracing for the camera to cut
away to me yeah I don't know yeah I
thought you were going to take a shot of
Todd pyro but I thought that was coming
yes all right New York City Police
nabbed a Smuggler with 300 000 fentanyl
laced pills stashed in the fuel tank of
his SUV cops say the drugs had a street
value of nearly a full tank of gas
this week the Surgeon General declared
loneliness and isolation as America's
newest epidemic
which is why we invited Todd on the show
tonight
two stories a little earlier I knew it
was coming yeah yeah yeah all right
funny man John Mulaney revealed he was
previously offered the hosting slot on
The Daily Show but decided instead to
stick with comedy
Uber has published its annual lost and
found list and includes items like a
lightsaber fog machine pets fake blood
and teeth and that was just from one
ride with Dana Perino
foreign
you don't know what she's up to after
the shows nothing good a federal jury
ruled this week that Ed Sheeran did not
copy parts of a Marvin Gaye song however
they did recommend a life sentence for
Ed's Barber
finally last Saturday President Biden
spoke at the annual White House
Correspondence Dinner Biden said he had
a great time and enjoyed talking to
former presidents Nixon and Reagan
[Applause]
yeah
yeah could have been funnier all right
did the Deep State help Joe Biden's fate
it's true they signed a bogus letter to
elect a pants sweater
newly released emails show former acting
CIA director Michael Morrell had
ulterior motives when he wrote the 2020
letter discrediting Hunter's laptop and
the motives stink worse than Joy behar's
jog bra
I mean assuming she jogs oh wait there
she is
[Applause]
you know the letter it was signed by a
51 former Intel officials claiming the
laptop was Russian disinfo a claim as
credible as a Prius winning the
Indianapolis 500. it's the biggest lie
since if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor which I told my staff
before eliminating their Health Plan
Morel admitted drafting The hoax as a
talking point for Joe to use in the
debate with President Trump through Joe
needed all the help you could get with
his talking points most of the time he
can't talk or point
hell he needs help with his walking
points
Morrell urged CIA boss John Brennan to
sign the letter and admitted he was
deliberately trying to help Biden's 2020
campaign and Brennan immediately
reported the corruption to the American
public
no he didn't just kidding he said add my
name to the list good initiative and
thanks for asking me to sign
I bet he blames Russia when he forgets
his anniversary
so some of the highest ranking Intel
officials with obvious political
motivations teamed up to help knock the
guy they didn't like out of the White
House it was basically a silent coup by
the Deep State a swamp deep enough to
hold Ted Kennedy's car
too soon
and while 51 officials played along some
didn't in fact the cia's former Moscow
station Chief Daniel Hoffman refused to
sign it because there was no evidence of
Russian involvement and you know he's
just the former Moscow station Chief
what the hell does he know they should
have asked AOC you know back in the day
she knew how to pour a decent White
Russian
I wonder what Joe thinks
no no no look look I didn't even have to
tell me about that before the debate I
knew what to do if you run into trouble
you you just do you blame it on the
Russians that's what you do I knew that
but they they were looking out for me my
buddies at the FBI and the CIA is no
harm no foul that's how I do it I get by
with a Little Help from My Friends
I get high with a Little Help from My
Friends
I'm gonna try With a Little Help from My
Lee welcome back to the show you know uh
I still wish you weren't here and
Governor but what can we do so who's who
was president at the time Trump who
developed this deep State why to get rid
of trump how is this not considered like
a soft coup
exactly what it is first red flag John
Brennan signs it yes I remember when
something would get signed by former CIA
officials and we'd say well this has to
be true yeah because there's no way that
they would go along with it because they
are not political they would want to
protect the institution as being bigger
than politics and so many different
institutions we see are being eroded by
the left we can talk education we could
talk about the criminal justice system
but we see inside the intelligence
community and now when people see in the
future something signed by 51 Former
Intelligence Officers you no longer can
say well this has to be true I'm a
Former Intelligence officer when I
signed up to be an intelligence officer
it was for our country yeah used to
protect our national security it was
love of our nation and our freedom and
unfortunately they're eroding what we
love yeah it's true like you know if
you're going to sign something sign a
petition to get like Homeland back on
Showtime
foreign
no it wasn't Homeland was a great show
you don't want to go down this road
the first season was amazing but then
they killed Brody and it was all down
yeah
our intelligence officials are about as
crazy and stupid as the people on
homeland that's what bothers me about
this is the complete lack of Common
Sense among these Intel officials
Hunter Biden there were photos in the
original report you know the cigarette
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay Hunter Biden is
a crack huff and corrupt oily
um
reprobate who had to get a brand new set
of teeth for his daddy to run for
president so we look slightly less
repellent and you're going to vouch in
this letter and say it's not Hunter
Biden's laptop you know that's going to
blow up in your face like referring your
nephew for a job at your employer
because you know that schave is gonna
smack the HR lady on the ass and call
her sugar cushions and you're gonna get
fired it's the same thing
[Applause]
thank you
have sugar cushions that was my nickname
in high school
still is but it is it is
when I'm in high school I met like 10
years ago
right
pyro how are you what's up sugar
cushions yeah
real estate on the side no me will Kane
and you
we go out we work for Coldwell Banker
you know what's amazing because we just
joke is we all look like real estate
agents or at least he does on a show
five weeks ago yeah so yeah that's a
call back so
um the media was salivating over smoking
guns on Trump that and they never found
one right and now here's the Smoking Gun
this letter but it's under Biden and
somehow not interested I mean you can't
you can't betray your media bias more
clearly but it's also that instance of
hey we're doing the thing that is wrong
so we're going to accuse the other side
of doing the thing that is wrong even
though there is no evidence of the other
side doing that thing but I think Lee
really hit the nail on the head when he
talked about the top levels of the Intel
agencies basically betrayed the trust
that America has put in those agencies
over the cost of decades all to win a
debate talking point because they were
so consumed with not having Trump ruin
their institutional power for another
four years and I think we need to break
it down to that base level to see what
they did and why did they do it well one
they want to drop out the two there are
no consequences to anybody on the left
for doing that can you think of one
prosecution that any of those people who
did anything to Trump with the Russian
collusion narrative has been put through
I'll wait I don't know and that's the
problem if there's no consequences to
the upper levels there's no consequences
to the criminals on the streets in New
York City are countries descending into
chaos and it's wrong yeah and you know
what they act like it's God's work cat
like even though they knew it was wrong
like that dude Peter strzok you know the
insurance policy dude it's like oh but
we are you know we are we are doing the
right thing so we'll be rewarded
somewhere
yeah it just sucks that all the rest of
us got to do all of our debates and
arguments on our own you know yeah yeah
you know how many times I'd love to be
like oh yeah boom Memo from the feds yes
that's true you know I gotta be coming
up with all this stuff all by myself
that's true that's true it's just crazy
he straight up says I'm trying to do
this for the campaign right I'm doing
this to try to influence the election to
go the way that I want it to go he
straight up says that which is very
different from what the letter said the
letter was so like well you know like it
was like well you're an idiot if you
don't think this yeah so they all think
we're really stupid and we've obviously
known that for a while but it's
completely ridiculous and unfair and
just saying we're doing this for the
campaign and all those people did it
I mean that's crazy yeah well I guess it
well there are all of those people that
signed it we're looking forward to
getting some kind of work somewhere else
so they knew that if you got people like
Brennan in charge like anybody asking
you you have to maintain those you know
those relationships so your influence
it's it's it's it's got to be illegal I
don't know what do I know I'm not a
lawyer no but you probably would be if
you had a memo from the feds exactly
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else